[Music]
from our home professor Keith Baker
who's a physicist he's going to tell us
something about the Higgs boson today
but first before we do that how many of
you are are going the students here are
thinking about going to college right
how many of you think you could you
could have your parents can afford to
send you to Yale okay so so everyone
that put their hands down put them back
up because your parents can't afford to
send you to Yale right now the parents
are going now what the hell is he
talking about
right there's no way I can afford to
send my kids to Yale
actually you can Yale's got a very
fantastic financial aid sort of program
we have approaching 20% of the student
body are now first-generation to attend
college all right so there's been a big
push to make certain that we have all
sorts of diversity including
socio-economic diversity and I don't
remember all the numbers but the the
most recent ones I was familiar with if
your total family income right is under
a hundred fifty thousand a year and
that's most families in the United
States all right Yale guarantees that
you will spend no more than 10% of that
to send your kids to Yale now you're
thinking 15,000 well that's that's you
know that's more than then the the
tuition at UConn which is 12 well that's
right but that's total that's tuition
and room and board you can't send your
kids many places with or where the room
and board is actually less than 15,000
so it's actually cheaper to send your
kids to Yale than to have them stay home
all right
so boot him out the door right right and
send him here okay all right so so Keith
otherwise known as okay Baker the
particle physicist chemist and actually
gay Pete's keep the piece of equipment
nuts so many years ago right I don't
think he's going to talk about that
today but but you know we all we all
work together he got his bachelor's
degree at MIT and physics I believe
right then he did his ph.d
at Stanford right went on he became a
went to Los Alamos National Labs in New
Mexico as a postdoc and then he became a
faculty member at Hampton University I'm
not sure where that is but we were lucky
enough to then attract him to Yale where
he he came here in 2006 yep 2006 and at
the time was the director of Wright
nuclear structure lab and so he's been
here working at the frontiers of
particle physics for quite some time and
he's got a really interesting story to
tell you so join me in welcoming Keith
[Applause]
ok so I'll I'll try to also speak up as
I as I get going so let me first of all
thank professor zoom for giving me this
opportunity to speak to you it's a
pleasure it's an honor to be here to
speak to you today so as he said I have
been at Yale for just over 12 years now
and also I wanted to point out to you
that I've been doing this science this
physics this has been my passion since I
was your age 12 11 or 12 years old this
is all I've ever wanted to do and I have
finally a chance to do it I wanted to
tell you not about all of particle
physics not even about all that I have
done but just to give you a flavor for
what I think is are some of the
highlights of the things that I've done
over all these years just some of the
highlights so I wanted to talk to you
about the Higgs boson the dark universe
and what comes next so this is what this
is our universe as we know it I mean
start this out I hope that this works
[Music]
yeah so this is the universe's so it
doesn't it doesn't come up here I guess
all right doesn't matter we'll skip it
sorry about that so this is our universe
as we know it it's filled with stars
with galaxies with clusters of galaxies
it's filled with interstellar gas it's
filled with planets and there may be
there's evidence really confirmed
recently that there are black holes and
in space all of this is what we see and
this is a Hubble Space Telescope image
of all these clusters of galaxies and
stars so as a particle physicist as a
scientist the same as professor zoom I
asked myself we asked ourselves what is
the world made of what's the universe
made of what holds the world together
where we come from this is what
scientists have been doing for many
millennia going all the way back to the
start of civilization maybe without
Aristotle and and others so this is what
we're doing
so after all of these years we finally
have an explanation of our universe as
we know it so here we are this is us so
this is what we call the classical
regime where you know you have living
beings like us and we're May and then of
course computer chips our hair all of
this so we believe we know sorry that
we're made of cells these are made of
molecules the molecules are made of
atoms the atoms are made of an atomic
nucleus surrounded by all of these
electrons depending on the type of atom
that it is and then the città atomic
nucleus is made of nucleons protons and
neutrons so everything around us the
chairs the seats that you're sitting in
the clothes that you wear you yourself
this is what we're made of and we can do
more than that we know how to trace time
going all the way back to when the
universe was
came into existence with this big bang
it wasn't an explosion it was more a
rapid expansion of time and space but
these elementary particles then gave way
to atoms that then form stars and these
stars of what made the heavy elements
the carbon that is the and other heavy
elements that form our earth then we had
these planetary systems that emerge from
there and then it goes on from there we
know that we can now tell you what
happens going back all the way fourteen
point seven billion years ago and
regions of space there are many many
light-years from where we are now we
also have a model a theory of how all of
this works it's called a standard model
of particle physics so over the last 100
years or so a combination of quantum
mechanics and Einstein's theory of
special relativity these were brought
together and to make up the standard
model confirmed with all of our
accelerators all of our experiments
about these new particles and they led
to this standard model of particle
physics so we know now that these
molecules that are made of atoms the
atoms are made of nuclei
I'm sorry of a nucleus and electrons and
then these nuclei are made of quarks and
gluons so we know that now from all of
these experiments that we've done we
know that there are six flavors of
quarks up down charm strange top and
bottom we know that there are these
leptons we call them leptons they're
electrons and positrons nu plus mu minus
tau plus and tau minus they're also
neutral up leptons neutrinos electron
muon and tau neutrinos we know that
there are four fundamental forces we
know that there's the electromagnetic
force we know there's the strong nuclear
force there's the weak nuclear force and
there's the gravitational interaction we
know now that what gives rise to the
weak force are these W and Z bosons we
know what gives rise to the
electromagnetic interaction is light
photons
we know what gives rise what mediates
the strong interaction and these are the
gluons inside of these nucleons so this
standard model that we have is not just
that we that a model was devised to fit
the data in some cases even predictions
were made and found to be true the
standard model of particle physics is
called the most successful theory ever
developed with the standard model again
we can understand our universe over over
energy scales that are just fantastic
many many factors of 10 over distance
scales that include clusters of galaxies
all the way down to elementary particles
inside of a nucleus if the crowning
achievement of 20th century science and
the standard model has been tested
thousands of times lots and lots of
different experiments and it's always
shown to be successful there are other
theories and again in particle physics
we call this the most successful theory
ever developed and we can debate that if
you like however there's a problem with
the standard model in order for the
standard model to work so well all of
the particles in it have to be massless
they cannot contain any mass if they
contain mass then the standard model
didn't work so the last thing that had
to be done with this wonderful
successful theory is to figure out how
do particles get their mass how do
elementary particles get their mass we
know that they do we know we have mass
and we're made of these elementary
particles we know that the clothes we
wear the chairs are sitting the cars we
drive the buses we take care all of that
so they have all of this has mass where
does that what did the elementary
particles get their mass so let's start
then at the top we're made of these
cells cells made of DNA molecules and
then there are these atoms we know that
most of the mass of the molecule comes
from the atom we know now where the mass
of the nucleus comes from these atoms
are made
electrons and nuclei the nuclei are what
carry most of the mass of the atom now
when you have these nucleons these
protons and neutrons that are separated
they have a certain mass this nucleus
has a different mass you bring all of
those protons and neutrons together
they'll have a different mass why is
that it's because when these are brought
together they have a binding energy it's
the binding energy of the nuclei that
makes it have its mass that it does it's
the binding energy between these
nucleons the protons and neutrons that's
what gives rise to the mass so for
example if you have protons and neutrons
and a carbon atom six protons six
neutrons surrounded by these electrons
this is how the carbon atom the basic
constituent of life here on this planet
gets its man it's the binding energy now
what about what the nucleus is made of
the nucleus ISM is not a fundamental
particle it's made of protons and
neutrons how do they get their mass well
the protons and neutrons are made up of
quarks so let's just take as an example
the proton the proton is made of two up
quarks and one down quark in the
Constituent quark model and there's
other stuff going on in here and I'll
come to that just in a second now these
these quarks these up quarks and down
quarks they changed gluons this is how
the strong force works the mediator of
the strong force is are these gluons and
this is where the proton gets its mass
from it gets it from these gluons and
their interactions with these quarks
okay so there can be lots of poor
Canaccord pairs which shown here and
they are connected by and they interact
with other constituents inside of a
proton or inside of a neutron with these
gluons this is where the majority of the
mass of a nucleon comes from but now
look now all of our experiments tell us
that these quarks are fundamental they
are elementary they're not made of
anything else they are called
fundamental particles the same with
electrons and muons and tau leptons they
are not made of anything else
they are just a fundamental particle
that are indivisible so the question is
how do they get their mass they don't
have this binding energy that we talk
about to give mass to the nucleus and to
the nucleons so this was the last piece
of this standard model in order for it
to work as well as it did we had to
understand what mechanism gave rise to
these fundamental particles like quarks
and leptons what gives them mass so this
is the story so it's not just that they
have mass why is it that there's such a
difference in mass why is it that the up
and down quarks have masses that in we
we talk about mass in terms of energy
units it's a few MeV up to like 10 MeV
whereas the heaviest particle that we
know of is the top pork why is its mass
so large it has a mass of 175 GeV a
hundred thousand times that are more of
some of these quarks here so this was
the thing that as Kurt said when I got
here this was this was the this is what
got me up in the morning among other
things was to try to find out what was
this if this was the right mekin what
was the mechanism that gave these
fundamental particles their mass there
were competing ideas let me just say
they were competing ideas having to do
with extra dimensions or with
supersymmetry this was just one of
several hypotheses about how particles
get their mass so this one is called the
Higgs mechanism named after Peter Higgs
and Francois Englert the mass mystery we
thought could be solved by the Higgs
mechanism which predicted the existence
of a new elementary particle never
before seen a fundamental scalar
particle some people called it the god
particle some called it the Higgs
particle and that's what will go away so
we call this the Higgs mechanism so the
Higgs had been searched for for decades
lots and lots of people from around the
world at all kinds of accelerators and
all kind of experiments had look for it
and couldn't find it we
looking they we collectively looked in
different regions of spate of
phase-space
mass versus coupling and no one ever saw
it
so finally we knew that we knew I'd
coupled to mass if it really existed but
we didn't know its mass we didn't know
how heavy it was so that was why we had
to build this Large Hadron Collider in
Geneva Switzerland so the first thing so
this new discovery required these really
gigantic detectors these gigantic
instruments that record the resulting
particles they as they stream out of
these collisions we had also had to have
a large accelerator the largest
accelerator in the world the most
energetic accelerator in the world was
is the Large Hadron Collider at this
point it's a powerful machine that
accelerates these particles and in this
case protons to extremely high energies
and brings them into collisions with
other particles we also had to have
really fast computers and we had to have
more than that we not only had to have
fast and powerful computers but we also
had to be able to make all of these
computers work together we had to be
able to get all the data and distribute
it to all of these people all around the
world who were working at the LHC 7,000
of us more more or less and this was
something else that had so not only did
we had to build the accelerator and the
detectors we also had to have computing
to collect store distribute and analyze
the vast amounts of data produced by
produced by these detectors and the
technology was just wonderful but let me
also say in my opinion as impressive as
the technology is the best part of
working on this is working with the
people involved it took some really
dedicated people who were willing to
work together collaboratively just the
collaboration that I worked in the Atlas
collaboration had over 3,000 scientists
and engineers from almost three dozen
countries speaking different Lane
which is different politics during the
time that I worked at the LHC now since
it's been over 20 years we've even gone
to war with some of these countries and
I'm going over there and we still found
a way to work together there you know
things say it so working with the people
has been the most exciting the best part
of being on in this collaboration let me
also say especially for the young people
here the worst part of being in the
collaboration is working with all these
people as well okay it cuts both ways
everybody thinks they're the smartest
person on the planet okay fine all right
I want to see if this works because it
shows how the LEC it may not work
sorry about that I went over these
slides with my wife and she said still
pictures is just gonna put everybody to
sleep so I had some motion pictures to
show you but okay it's not working so
here we go all right so we collide these
particles and the protons come in from
this side and this side of this Atlas
detector here and they collide right
here in the center and just to give you
a sense of scale this is the size of an
average person here compared to this big
device that was built by all of these
scientists worldwide and I won't go
through all of these details what's
important I want to bring out our two
things one it's about almost 50 meters
long about 12 meters in radius it weighs
about 7,000 tonnes and what I'm told is
that even if the way it's built and if
you were to drop it in the middle of the
Atlantic it would still float at least
for a while anyway
the other thing I want to point out is
this inter detector the very first thing
the very first thing that happens when
these particles collide as you start to
detect the debris and that debris is
right here in this the initial formation
of this debris is right here in the
inter detector and this is one of the
things that I did this took 10 years out
of my life building these what's called
a transition radiation tracker and when
I say me it was a group of really doubt
dedicated fabulous people that I worked
with and this thing was finally built
okay so now what happens all of that
debris that comes out of these
collisions we have to sift through what
is it what is important what is exciting
and what's not then we start to collect
the data what you're shown here coming
in this is a time lapse slide that shows
how the data is collected over many many
months and so what you see here in red
is the background we knew that this
background existed and we see the data
fits it but then there was this thing
right here this little peak here right
at 125 GeV that had never been seen
before
this was the Higgs boson this was this
new Bose
it looks it looks a lot like the Higgs
and it probably is so that's what we are
so after I started working on this when
I was in my early 30s and I we finally
found this when I came here to Yale and
it's just a wonderful feeling I have to
tell you there were seven thousand
people who were part of this new
discovery everyone worked hard there
were people who worked on this much
longer than idea there were people doing
this for even more than the twenty years
that I've worked on this but being a
part of a new discovery being a part of
this thing that completes the most
successful theory ever developed it's
just a wonderful feeling okay and it's
just wonderful even now I still just
don't I would tell my grandchildren
about this and I'll embellish the story
to make myself look more important than
that Wow okay so now we know now we know
how elementary particles get their mass
and this is how it how it's done and
I'll start by giving an analogy so what
would happen if Lady Gaga or Gosling
were to walk into this room I think it's
Gosselin you would want to shake their
hand you'd want to get their autograph
you would want to interact with them
somehow
and if they were coming in here to try
to get a seat they would have a harder
time they would have to go through all
of you wanting to interact with them to
get to their seat whereas if I walked
into this room nobody cares I just
walked right to my seat and everything
is fine this is the analogy with the
Higgs mechanism so we now know that
there's this Higgs field it permeates
all of space it's an invisible energy
field
that's everywhere in the universe and
the particles that pass through it some
particles like the photon pass right
through it they don't interact with this
Higgs field they don't interact with it
at all
so they can travel at the speed of light
and they have no mass this photon is a
massless particle there are other
particles like these like quarks or
the electrons or muons they interact
with it somewhat feebly they have sort
of feeble interactions so what happens
then is they gain a small mass and they
have to travel less at a speed less than
the speed of light because they have
mass and then we have the heavier
particles like the Z boson the W boson
the Higgs or the top for the top pork is
the heaviest particle we know is it
interacts really really strongly with
this Higgs field and that's why its mass
is so large because it interacts heavily
with this big field and it has a
velocity that's much less than the speed
of light for a given energy so that's
the way the Higgs mechanism works this
is the way a limit of particles get
their mass and of course Peter Higgs and
Francois Englert won the Nobel Prize for
this and the closest I came to winning a
Nobel Prize is I was the Atlas and CMS
experiments were mentioned and that's
perfectly fine so now here's the
standard model of particle physics the
standard model we now know has 36 quarks
there are these six flavors of quarks I
showed you each of them has three colors
and two charges we know also that there
are eight of these gluons that mediate
this strong force we know that there are
six charged leptons new muons electron
and positron and towels we know that
there are three neutral leptons these
neutrinos electron muon and tau
neutrinos we know about the force
carriers we know that there's one
neutral Z boson to dub two charged
bosons w+ and w- and the photon and now
finally we know that this Higgs boson
exists this is a scalar particle the
first of its kind ever seen so there are
58 known elementary particles in the
standard model but however there are
lots of reasons to believe that this
isn't the final answer some people ask
me how can you say this is the greatest
theory ever developed of the greatest
model if it doesn't include gravity
and the answer is as my theory colleges
will tell you blaming the standard model
for not describing gravity is like
blaming your toaster oven for not giving
you orange juice that's not what it was
designed to do the standard model was
designed to explain the strong
electromagnetic and weak interactions
and it does it wonderfully brilliantly
but our universe is a little more
complicated than that
there's more than just these particles
that I've shown in fact in fact this is
what our universe looks like all of
these stars and galaxies all of these
black are these school sorry
interstellar gas all of these planets
all of this is just this tiny sliver of
the total mass and energy budget in the
universe all the stars all of this
interstellar gas the planets all of this
only accounts for about 4% of the
universe most of the universe is made up
of we now know we just we well we label
it dark matter and dark energy we don't
know what they are we don't know what
this is we don't even know if it has a
particle physics solution it may be a
solution that's beyond us but as a
particle physicist this is what I do to
try to see if there's a particle physics
solution to what is dark energy that
makes up almost 3/4 of the total mass
energy budget of the universe and this
dark matter and then there are other
questions one of them is just sort of
what happened to the antimatter if the
universe was we know the universe began
as this rapid expansion of time and
space called the Big Bang and if that's
the case there were particles made and
there were anti particles made all of
our experiments all my experience all
the work I've ever done and all the work
that my colleagues have done have shown
when you create a particle in your
laboratory you create a new particle you
also create an anti particle to go with
it at the moment of the Big Bang this
had to have happened and particles and
antiparticles when they meet they
annihilate each other and they just give
energy so
why is it then that the entire universe
isn't just filled with energy with
photons if you look out into space
you see that's almost the case there
many many more photons of energy then
then there is matter but there is matter
we exist so somehow another something
had to separate matter from antimatter
so that all of this could happen
all of these are mysteries and they're
more what is it dark matter what's dark
energy what happened to the antimatter
so the solution is probably what we call
a dark sector this is what we are now
calling it because for reasons that I
will explain later but we don't know
what it is we don't know what dark
matter is just like there are force
carriers between the particles in the
standard model there could be forced
carriers between these dark matter
particles and there could be something
even more elaborate than that we just
don't know so we're calling it a dark
second and this is what we're doing now
so I wanted to just show you some of the
evidence for it all right
so one of them has to do with the way
that these galaxies rotate this is
what's called this is the the speed at
which this galaxy goes around okay so
most of the mass of a galaxy that we can
see anyway is right in the center and as
you start to go out to the edges there's
less and less of this luminous matter as
you can see I said luminous because you
can see it with your telescopes on earth
so if you just look at the luminous
matter this is the way the speed should
look as a function of the distance from
the center of this this galaxy it should
maybe rise like this and then it should
fall off but it doesn't do that it
actually follows a different curve it
doesn't fall off it's it continues to be
at this healthy rate up here very much
higher than what's expected what this
suggests is that there's more matter
inside of here than what you can see all
of this luminous matter is just a small
part of the total matter that's in this
in this this galaxy and you can see this
in different kinds of galaxies spiral
and elliptical galaxies for example you
see
the same thing in all of them there's
more matter inside of here than can be
accounted for with all of these this
luminous matter stars and galaxies and
quasars and all of that
another example has to do with
gravitational lensing so if we look at
distant stars the light that comes from
these distant stars that come to us on
earth and hits our detectors has certain
features to it and that is it has these
rings around it so just like if I were
to put photons send them through a lens
these photons can be bent giving it a
lens you can focus them or you can make
them diverge when the light comes from
these distant galaxies they pass through
this dark matter and they too have this
lensing effect so for example these
rings that go around here or the way
that they are show up in our telescopes
this is called gravitational lensing and
this is one of the reasons why we know
that there has to be something else out
there and then the other one this
actually happened just a couple years
before I came here to Yale the bullet
cluster so these are clusters of
galaxies clusters of galaxies and each
of the galaxies had galaxies has
billions of stars
so these clusters of galaxies came
together over many many millennia and
they collided and they passed through
each other
so when they when these galaxies
collided we saw that all the particles
they collided here they're shown in red
this is the heat or the light that comes
from these stars these collisions all of
it was sort of kept right here in the
center of this collision where as we
knew now if you look at gravitational
lensing and there are other other
effects that there's a lot more mass out
here in blue shown in blue here then can
be seen there's a lot more of it and
it's called we call it again
dark matter this was a smoking gun this
is another one of the smoking guns it
says there has to be more going on here
than just what we see in the standard MA
so there then believe me there's other
evidence as well so whatever this dark
matter and these Dark Matter carriers
are these dark forces or Dark Sector we
know that it's non luminous it doesn't
give off light we know that it has a
very small feeble interaction with us
with the standard model the only the
only evidence that we have of it is
through the gravitational interaction
and that's the weakest of all the known
forces we know that just the standard
model just the 4% of the universe that
we know and we know extremely well has
58 different kinds of particles in it so
it's naive to think that whatever this
dark matter is that it's just one
component there could be lots of
different dark matter or dark sector
particles with different components and
whatever it is it dominates the matter
budget of the universe
it's the predominant way that our
universe was formed so all of this you
don't have to know is this is just sort
of the jargon we use we can say that
whatever these particles are if it's a
particle physics solution they're either
going to be vector or a pseudo scalar or
scalar or they're going to be fermions
they're gonna have half energy spin
that's what this is telling you so
they're very so we find ways to look for
all of these kind of particles that
could be a dark matter particle so I'll
show you a couple of examples one has to
do with kinetic mixing with the photon
or with the Z boson so that was Dark
Matter now this dark energy dark energy
is a mystery the very best theories that
we have the standard model of particle
physics when we try to apply it to
explain dark energy we're off by over a
hundred orders of magnitude 10 to the
120 to the power of 120 that says we
have no idea of what dark energy is dark
energy what it does is at the time of
the Big Bang when you had all of this
mass and energy in a small region of
space then it
to expand very rapidly but all of the
matter and energy is still enclosed in
this region of space that is expanding
so that means that all of this matter is
pulling back on it as it expands the
gravitational interaction is saying you
got to slow down because that's what
gravity is an attractive force so what
this says then is that if this is the
moment of the Big Bang and this is going
into the future
we wondered well the universe is
expanding but because all this matter
and energy that's enclosed inside the
universe is pulling on it it's going to
expand to a certain point but then it's
gonna start to come back in on itself
this was the Big Bang and this is gonna
be called a Big Crunch the universe is
just going to come back in on itself and
explode after many many billions of
years another possibility is at the time
of the Big Bang as the universe was
expanding its expanding at a rate that
it's just going it's going to slow down
but it's going to continue to sort of
have this this this this size the size
of universe and it's just going to
meander along forever another
possibility is that after the Big Bang
the universe was expanding and it's
expanding at such a rate that is still
going to always expand but at our
various at a much lower rate than than
right at the moment of the Big Bang but
we now know that none of those are true
when I was a junior faculty just
starting to teach my students I told
them this I told them that you know
these are the three possibilities of our
universe but I was wrong completely
wrong we now know that not only is the
universe expanding but it's speeding up
as it expands it is an accelerated
expansion of the universe so the
universe at some point is just going to
become so huge and dark and cold that no
life can exist in it but it won't happen
you know in your lifetime billions of
years from now the other thing we know
is that it's temporal if the amount of
dark energy that exists now existed at
the moment of the Big Bang here
none of us would exist so it's temporal
it changes with time we have no idea
what what causes that it could be
something that we just haven't thought
of have no idea of yet and all this is
just data I won't go through this it
just shows that that the universe four
critical density where the universe
followed one of these scenarios this
data that show Nia would have to be
somewhere down here and if it was way up
here we could probably explain it with
the standard model but it's just barely
here she's barely above this critical
density so we don't know how to explain
this this is what this is telling us so
that's the dark energy so what's the
properties whatever dark energy is it
opposes the gravity it counteracts
gravity gravity wants to pull all the
matter in dark energy says no we're not
only going to counter it but it's so
much a dark energy that the universe
isn't just expanding it's speeding up
it's accelerating as it expands it has a
time dependence its temporal its
ubiquitous it's everywhere it accounts
for almost three-quarters of the mass
energy budget of the universe so when I
say we have no idea what it is that
doesn't mean that we don't try okay so
there are two possibilities that people
sort of sing Albert Einstein claimed
that there may have been well in his day
there was a claim that there was just
cosmological constant it's just a theory
that says that in space there's this
constant of energy and this is what's
causing it there's also this thing
called the quintessence model and this
is what excites me because this says in
the quintessence model that there are
particles that give rise to this dark
energy and I'll give you a couple of
examples of this so let's talk about
some experimental searches and I'm just
going to give you a few examples there
are many many more but these are
examples of what I have I have worked on
so let's talk about this
this vector portal where there's this
kinetic mixing versus the mass of
whatever this particle is now all the
experiments that have been done up to
now all the experiments are what's shown
in these these colored regions here so
in this color regions what I show here
this is the coupling of whatever this
dark matter particle or dark sector
particle is this is its coupling to
stand a model to the standard model
particle versus here along this axis is
the mass of that particle and we give it
in energy units and electron volts so
this is a log scale so this goes from 10
to the minus you know 17 all the way up
to 10 to the plus 12 electron volts
pterri electron volts so and everything
that's shown in white here has not been
explored this is a region of parameter
space that has not been explored yet we
haven't come up with a clever enough
experiment to do it to probe whether
this thing has a coupling in this range
and whether it has a mass somewhere in
this range or in this range so this is
what it looks like sort of today and
this is the first this is one of the
regions that had not been explored and I
wanted to do this when I was a part of
the Higgs discovery so let me set this
up why what's different now what would
you do that's different well let's take
an example of Galileo Galileo after
learning of this new tool this telescope
Galileo was so telescopes were
originally invented so that you could
see enemy ships coming to your city from
distance and you could prepare yourself
to fight ok defend yourself
Galileo and instead pointed his
telescope at the moon and he discovered
mountains mountains on the moons he also
discovered the telescope was used for
the discovery of moons on Jupiter that
planets orbited the Sun and not the
earth telescopes tell us that the Sun
has sunspots the the lesson here is with
new tools there's opportunity if you in
your lifetime have some new discovery or
some new technology you should think
about how can this be
to make some new discovery or maybe
solve these problems so this is what I
worked on since I've been since I've
been here and been a part of the Higgs
discovered the next thing was can this
Higgs sector because this is unlike any
other particle in the standard model can
it couple to this hidden sector or a
dark sector this is the thing that I'm
looking at and also all this is just
jargon it means this is the standard
model stuff over here the Higgs couples
to all the standard model we know how it
does it does it couple to this dark
sector so this is what this is how the
experiment analysis was done let me just
say this okay this is no time to be
humbled okay because I just spent too
much time so I'm gonna tell you I didn't
come up with this theory but I was the
one who pioneered this analysis at the
LHC I was the one who said okay what if
now we look in this channel where this
takes the case to for leptons in the
final state but now instead of this
Higgs just coupling to stand and model
particles like the standard model Z
boson what if it couples to something
that's beyond the standard model a dark
Z a dark vector boson
so the collisions at the LHC that these
are proton-proton collisions at these
high energies it's mainly the gluons
that are scattering so this is called
gluon gulen fusion so the gluons inside
the proton are what you what are really
colliding in these in these collisions
they give rise to the Higgs which we've
seen and then I look for evidence for
this dark Z and in the interest of time
I probably won't go through just the
details this is just the strategy that I
proposed and it was fine it was accepted
but since 2000 and the end of 2012 after
the Hebrews was discovered until now we
look forward and we've seen nothing
there's no evidence for this where this
dark Z would kinetically mix with the
standard model Z and we would look for
some peak in that spectrum and that's
what this is saying we look for some
peak in this offcial distribution of the
Z boson this dye left on in
Varian mass distribution we see no
evidence for it I'll give you another
example light shining through a wall
okay in this case what happens if I have
a laser shining photons and these
photons okay I don't know what I'm doing
but okay I'm too close to their mic okay
so just as neutrinos can morph from one
type to another what if these photons
can morph into this dark sector particle
is just call it X so you have a very
powerful laser you put this laser into
you point it at this wall here and
during the course of its travel from the
laser to this wall what if this thing
were to kinetically mix or morph into a
dark sector particle now these things
are feeble they have very small
interactions with the standard model so
these would go right through this wall
whereas photons themselves if they did
not kinetically mix with this dark
sector particle they would bounce off
this wall they can't go through the wall
so if it kinetically mixes with this
dark sector particle this can go through
the wall and then the same mechanism
that made it mix over here would now
make this mix back into a photon a
standard mom proton that you would
detect in your detector so you'd have
light coming over here and if you saw
light in your detector you knew in a
properly designed experiment the only
way this could happen is you had a
process like this this would happen in
free space you can also pass this
through a magnet and look not just for
vector particles but this could be a
scalar particle or a pseudo scalar
particle and that's what these light
shining through wall experiments when
you have a magnet can do you
these would via what's called the prima
coffee effect they would convert into
these dark sector scalar and pseudo
scalar particles pass through the wall
and then you put another magnet on the
other side of the mall wall and make it
convert back into a photon that you
detect in your detector so these were
experiments that I started at the
Jefferson Lab free electron laser this
at the time was the most powerful source
of photons in the world and this was the
experiment we had a magnet here we
magnin here this was the laser light
coming in and here was the wall that we
had here and here was our detector over
here and this is a photo of the setup
and we saw nothing we saw nothing the
only thing that I can brag about here is
that for the time this was the most the
the lips experiment this was the most
sensitive measurement in the world we
were the most sensitive at law and then
since then we've been outdone by other
groups and Switzerland Germany and at
Fermilab but it's fine for a brief while
I was very happy about this we saw
nothing you could also do the same thing
by pointing your detector at the Sun
there could be a lots of these Dark
Sector particles coming from the Sun
that maybe you can detect and there's a
big magnet that's called the CERN axial
and solar telescope for you point this
big cannon at the Sun and you track it
during the daytime so this is on a
device that allows it to rotate like so
and you can follow the Sun as it goes
across the sky and look to see if you
see evidence for something that the only
way it could get here is if it converts
inside of this magnet and you detect
them in your detect in your detective so
that was done still nothing
we saw nothing and that's been going on
now for many decades now actually I
think it's shutting down in the next
couple of years what about dark energy
what dark energy again we really don't
have a clue but there is this model I
can test against it's called the
quintessence model of dark energy so
what does that what is one example an
example of a quintessence particle is
what's called a chameleon particle and
as the name implies a chameleon particle
is a particle that its mass depends on
its environment if it's an empty space
that has zero mass but if it goes into
some region of space where there's matte
matter then its mass changes its mass
grows so you can use this and what we
did was to use this in the following way
here's a magnet here's a laser
you point this laser into your vacuum
chamber this is in vacuum and in some
cases these photons can convert into
this chameleon particle they can connect
with them in any feeling and make a
chameleon particle this chameleon now
has a certain energy so that when it
sees this vacuum window here and this
vacuum winner here it can't go through
them because it would have to have a
mass bigger than the energy that it has
so it just bounces around in here so you
can leave this laser on for a few
minutes or a few hours and try to fill
this whole space with chameleon
particles then you turn the laser off so
now there's no more light laser light
going through here so after some minutes
or hours the only way you would see
light here is if in a properly designed
experiment is if one of these chameleons
converted it back into a full time you
saw it so that was the that was another
experiment we did and we still see
nothing so here's how I want to conclude
I've talked to you about Dark Sector
particles dark matter dark messengers I
spoken to you about dark energy the
accelerated expansion of the universe
I've spoken to you about the different
tools that we use the LHC the Atmos
collaboration these big detectors and
[Music]
small tabletop experiments that I've
done in the lab right here on campus and
in other labs where you don't build a
big L a large hadron collider you don't
build that to do those experiments but
they still can give you a sensitivity
that you can't even get it the LHC but
what I want to end it with is the thing
that excites me the most this is where
the discovery is going to come from 10
or 15 years from now professor zoom is
going to invite one of you young people
that are in the audience right now he's
going to invite you to come back and
tell us what dark matter really is what
dark energy really is and you're going
to stand up here in front of all your
friends your parents and grandparents
your children and if you have any by the
end and you're gonna tell us what it is
and nothing that I've said today will be
in your talk it'll be in something new
[Applause]
course you are you don't stop yes it is
a property of the higgs field itself the
way that it couples the way that the
Higgs field couples the Higgs boson has
very specific properties if we can tell
you the coupling our standard model
tells us that to a great precision the
precision of just a few percent so what
it says is that a particle like a photon
should not couple at all or gluons
should not couple at all directly to the
to the Higgs that's a property of the
field and that's a property of the
particles that pass through it on the
other hand the top court has to it has
to interact very heavily with it and we
know how to calculate that it's not
something that just falls out of the air
it is something that people have spent
many decades prescribing this Higgs
field and that's just the way it works
yeah that's correct the Higgs field and
the particle that goes through it right
so I gave a talk let me just put let me
just put this out here because I gave a
talk in my home state of Arkansas some
years ago and there was a young person
like you who stood up and asked me can
you bottle the Higgs field can you
bottle it and the answer is I don't know
but no I don't think so because it
is pervasive it passes right through
it's everywhere so if you could bottle
it and somehow this energy field
converted into something that is useful
okay I wanted to get that out there
before you ask me a question now I was
you know I get embarrassed again so I
don't know there there are problems I
don't know that so I just followed up on
your question just to get it out there
okay
what if then what was there before the
Higgs oh yeah that's that's another good
question I don't know I I don't know
there okay there are lots of there are
lots of ideas let me just say this to
you if you want to go into science
always make sure that you have data to
support your ideas okay so data is
always that brick wall of reality right
their idea is that there are just lots
and lots of universes what's called a
multiverse we just happen to live in the
one of these many millions and billions
of universes that supports life all of
not all of them support life at least
not the life as we know it that's one
idea
another idea is that there's a universe
sort of within our universe that we are
coexisting with other particles there
could be a young woman just like you
made of a different kind of particle
that's sitting right in the same region
of space that you are but you don't
interact with it or you interact very
feebly with it all of these are ideas we
have no data to support them so it's a
really good question you ask and I I
don't know I don't know the answer what
existed before this universe
so we're all made of it at its basic
level molecules that are made of atoms
that are made of protons and neutrons
and electrons and the particles inside
of the nucleus inside of the nucleons
the quarks are mainly up and down quarks
not top quarks we don't have top quarks
in us the top quark decays immediately
when it's created decays immediately so
we would interact like up and down
quarks we're gonna interact not very
heavily like a top four but more than a
photon somewhere in between if because
that's how we're me we're made of these
up and down court and all are the chair
that you're sitting in all the car that
you drove your home that's what this
world is made of yeah so some
intermediate interaction strength yeah
I should
okay so you hit on another with a good
point you all asking really good
questions if the other the other part of
the Higgs that has to happen is the
Higgs has mass it's 125 GeV therefore
the Higgs has to interact with itself it
has there has to be a Higgs Higgs
interaction and we're looking for that
we're looking for that at the LHC until
then we actually don't know how it
interacts with itself we don't know
exactly why it's mass is what it is why
is the mass 125 GeV all of the theories
sort of suggested that it should have
had a higher mass than it does for
instance it's now at 125 GV gives rise
to some instability in the universe that
we don't understand yet but we will when
we see and study this Higgs interaction
the problem is that at the LHC well to
see this Higgs Higgs interaction you
need this is more jargon you need sort
of thousands of inverse femto Barnes
thousands three thousand inverse filter
Barnes to just see some evidence for the
Higgs interacting with itself right now
we only have even after running for
almost ten years we still only have like
a hundred to 150 inverse Hunter Barnes
so will we ever reach three thousand in
percent of Mars with this machine I just
don't know so it is a question we have
to understand that this is a big big
enterprise now at the LHC but
going to take many many years before we
get there if we get there at all because
we're going to upgrade this Large Hadron
Collider from the luminosity the number
of protons that collide we're going to
upgrade it and we will run the upgraded
LHC around 2026 2027 and running for 10
years and we'll see we'll see how close
we can get to that so until then the
questions you ask about the instability
of the universe and the Higgs
interaction has to wait yes sir
[Music]
so that's correct so spontaneous
symmetry breaking is this idea of
spontaneous symmetry breaking that you
describe actually did not come out of
particle physics it came out of
condensed matter physics and I guess in
chemistry and that is if I have like a
pencil that's or a pen or a needle even
that's very thin and I have it resting
on this tabletop so that it's just
sitting here no interactions it's very
very sensitive to you know falling over
one way or another just walking past it
will do it now that means that this
needle is symmetric it has a symmetry
around it in all directions it's not
until that needle falls over that it
chooses the direction in space now you
have a symmetry breaking and that's what
we call spontaneous symmetry breaking
the Higgs mechanism was like that the
Higgs mechanism is a result of
spontaneous symmetry breaking it's
called I should have brought a plot to
show this where you have a Mexican hat
potential you can have a Higgs particle
or some particle that's in there and
it's just it's at the top of the Mexican
hat and it could fall anywhere inside of
the ridge of the Mexican hat once it
does fall it chooses the direction that
breaks the symmetry and that's
spontaneous symmetry breaking so the
answer to your question is I actually
think you're in a better position if I
can just say it Kurt that to answer
there than I am because it didn't grow
out of particle physics you grow out of
your field okay so that's that's yeah
[Applause]
[Music]